what's going on with France the grown  nación is once again posted lackluster  growth results instead of spending the  French are sitting on what money they  have and fearful businesses are also  investing too little all in all there's  a distinct lack of Giada vivre in the  country's economy growth was flat in  France in the second quarter of 2015 an  expert's predictable lag behind the rest  of the eurozone for the year as a whole  next door in Germany things are still  ticking along its economy grew almost  half a percent quarter-on-quarter German  exporters profited from cheap oil and  the cheaper euro and domestic  consumption was strong boosted by  rock-bottom interest rates and low  unemployment Germans are building and  buying but not everything is rosy in  Germany either if growth continues to  drop off in China the most important  trading partner in Asia for many German  companies it could soon start making a  dent in bottom lines